Hey, Jim.
Hello.
Doing very well. Thank you so much for asking. I'm just waiting for Mohit to join in. He was here a minute ago and he was telling me Alex will also join this meeting.
Okay.
Cool.
That'll be great. After a long time, we'll see Alex.
Yeah.
Yeah, Karen is out of the office today, so she won't be on here.
It's good.
Yeah, she's on vacation.
Oh, that's nice. Someone is getting vacation. That's good. How many days is it? One week? Two weeks?
Reno.
Yeah. Yes, she's out this week. She's doing a bowling thing in Reno, Nevada.
Oh, that's nice. Las Vegas, huh?
Yeah, near Las Vegas.
Hey Jim, hey Kevin.
Hey, Mohit, we were discussing.
I don't.
No Karen today.
I don't see Karen here. What happened? Is she okay?
Yeah, she's on vacation, bro. She's playing Russian roulette, brother.
She's on vacation.
Ohh.
Seriously?
Yeah, she's having a good time and we are working.
The the the real Russian really we're talking about?
She is.
She's bowling in Reno, Nevada.
Oh, oh, okay, good for her then, good for her. What about you, Jim?
Yeah.
And after that, she'll be playing Russian Roulette.
The.
Jim, when are you gonna get that? When are you gonna get some?
Jim is imagining Kevin playing Rozario role in that. That's fun.
Ohh.
I don't know. I think I'm going to be taking vacation the last week of June and maybe sometime in August. We'll see.
Call, call.
Wait, wait.
I've been mulling it over.
Hmm, I'm sure Alex will approve it.
I would like.
Yeah, I would like you to invite to India. Come to India.
It should be a little way around Mohit. Alex should invite us to US so that we can together go and have some fun and play Russian roulette.
I got it.
Yeah.
Jim, Jim, you heard that? Now you have to plant the seed in his brain. Like, we need the ITBD team to be here.
Yes.
It.
Okay.
Yeah.
But.
I'll let him know.
Yeah.
I had to connect with Alex in the morning. I do think you were also on the call.
For Winston.
Yes, I was on that call.
Yes, so Alex said he'll be joining the service call. So would he be or can we start?
Um, yeah, I'm not sure. I don't...
I don't know if he plans on joining or not. He said, I think he said he was going to, but...
Yes, yes, that's why I'm just checking.
Maybe Mohit, if you could just ping him and see if he's available. If he says it's going to take him time, then we can start. If he says that just a couple of minutes, then we can wait.
That's a good idea. I like that idea.
I'm just going to ping.
Yeah, Alex.
Sounds like you might be on another call.
Yeah, the status is busy, so I'm sure he's on a different call.
Yes, most probably.
I just pinged him. Let's see if it responds.
He hadn't seen the message yet.
He's ignoring you, what?
Yeah, likely.
Just.
Do you know the reason why? Just because I'm a man? Is it so?
Yeah.
Because I don't wanna say it, maybe, maybe, yeah.
Please don't, please don't. No, do it.
He might be busy, I understand.
Yeah, I think it sounds like he's on another call, so...
Yes, it's right.
No, sure, then we can proceed with...
English.
We will tell him that we waited for you and you did not show up, so that's why we started.
Yeah, yeah, we're just gonna have to get started, I think.
And my message, my ping is also over there, so he might, you know, check and Bill be like, oh, sorry, I just missed that. No issues. Let's proceed with this service serial. Let me share the screen. Let me know once it's visible. Okay.
The presentation.
I see it.
Thank you everyone. Thank you gentlemen for joining today's service review for APMIT. We are going to conduct the service review from 8th of the April till 14th of the April. That's till yesterday.
Yeah.
Why is working so slow? The transition is killing me.
So today's agenda is going to be our partnership value drivers, the team data, way forward, and any queries that we have. So if I talk about our partnership value drivers, as we know, Winsay joined today and Animesh is going to join in the next week. And we are making our growth with strategic enablement of the accounts along with the resources as well.
Mm.
So let's move on to the next one. That will be the service review for Shivani Pandey. From the next week onward, I do think it will be for two people. Right now it is only for Shivani. So concluding the reports and after the confirmation with Alex, we have changed the view and now we can see that the total output for the workable utilization hours is third.
30 hours and 93 for five days. The operating baseline showcase the utilization is near about 65% and the peak utilization was for 124% on Thursday. That is 9th of the April. She scored like 1 1/2 hour on a user assistance issue regarding.
Mhm.
If you are the concern, so she was here for more than 1 1/2 hours, so that's concluded on that day as well.
Yeah.
Moving on to the next one, it is also talking about that near about two hours because I was also with her checking with the user with the issue. But yes, I do see on the other days, the optimization is not that much for the utilization, but yes, going way forward and providing value to a user issue that really stands out for me as well.
If I talk about the clients and how the schedule is working for her, so most of the clients are for National Forensic and Council of South. And most of the issues that have been included for the last week would be hardware failure issues.
Anything else that you would like to add, Jim, because we have received like free laptop and concerns regarding hardware only.
OK.
No, she was spending a lot of time with the failed laptop for Kelly Pines and National Forensics. And then, yeah, it's handling any other.
Mhm.
Yeah, as far as I know, that's what she was working on primarily.
Yes, I also confirmed with her and that were the only issue that we and that she was getting from the user ends. So this slide also talks about how on the other days the capacity was near about 40%. Oh, okay. Alex says, I'm on call with Wincent. He says, I'm on call with Wincenter.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm gonna share this snip with you.
Alrighty then.
I'll share it soon. Okay, so it's about the peak on Thursday that has already been discussed. So if I talk about the reactive and proactive task that she's been doing, so unplanned and high end urgency intervention was regarding clear laptop, email issues and password and other things. But as I'm also aware, she's also working on some project that has been provided by Alex and she's also including all those things.
Mhm.
things to work upon. I do think she has marked the mail. Alex has marked the mail to you, Jim, to review the devices and the segregation that he and she has done on the file. So if you can respond to that, that will be really good.
The same goes for the hardware cluster. I do think there were a lot of tickets for the hardware radius, right? And this week is the main concern.
Yeah, she, we had two, two hard two laptop failures, one for national forensics and one for council. She addressed a laptop that was booting in the safe mode for the council and I sent a replacement laptop and she's going to be working with the user to get them all set up on the replacement laptop.
Mhm.
I think she's going to be talking with her today about that.
Yes, because I can, as I can see, the other requests that were also pertaining on that time were they were, you know, pushed because of those tickets. So I do think they were high priority users on the other end.
Mhm.
Okay, moving on to the next one. So most of the tickets were from National Forensic and Council of South. Apart from that, I do see Mercer Street Prince. That's the project she's been doing. And a few tickets from Flagger and Apex Benefit Group. So this is the concentration of the ticket that she's receiving from. And this all just talks about it. So everything is about 9th April. She's like, you know, I give 1 1/2 hours more than the usual.
Yu.
Yeah, that's, that's interesting.
Yeah, but that actually focuses on the hardware request that we were getting and basically only two out of them.
Yeah.
So.
Yeah, yeah, I see she worked on both of the failed laptop issues that day, so...
Yes, yes.
And there's one more thing that I would really like. So we have isolated the hardware streams that was done, but as I have seen her, you know, the utilization board, I do see multiple tickets overlapping on a single time. I just wanted to check, like, you know, how the tickets been assigned to her because.
Sometimes what happens if we have to, you know, change them? I have seen, you know, Alex pointing it out for the tickets whenever there are like multiple tickets and they are working on that. So I do think the utilization is not being optimized because obviously you can't work on 2 tickets at a time in ConnectWise, right? So is there any workaround that we can look out for? Because obviously it will be simple.
Right.
suppressing her utilization for that timing as well.
Yeah, I mean, I definitely don't give her more than one thing to do at a time, so...
I don't know what's up with that. Let me take a look at our calendar.
Yes, you can check her with her scheduler as well.
Yeah, I mean, she definitely had some overlap yesterday.
Uh.
I have all the report the last week for like 2 to 3 days.
Alright, that was a close ticket.
Yeah, let's take a look at last week.
Put on week.
Excellent. All right.
10, right? Yes.
Yeah, Tim, my apologies. I need to drop. So Mohit, Jim, thanks so much for your time.
Aarti.
Thank you, Kevin. I'll take care of it from Ayra.
See you. See you next week. Take care. Bye.
Same, Evan. Thank you.
Yeah, I definitely see she does have stuff scheduled for the same time, especially on Friday. She had several items scheduled for the same time frame. Yeah, I'll make sure that doesn't happen. Obviously, yeah, we can't work on two things at the same time, so...
So.
Yes, yes.
Yes, if we can, yeah, if we can check in the morning huddle with Alex, because now Vincent would be, you know, joining the team and they'll also be working closely, so if we can, you know, get it rectified or maybe, you know, provide a rectification on all those scenarios, like how to approach in them and scheduling the tickets, that would be really great for her as well, because...
Mhm.
She's also trying to provide the, you know, the project insight as well, working on that along with the tickets and, you know, the incoming of new requests as well. So I also need her to be, you know, focused upon single tickets at a singular time so that, you know, she's not hodgepodging here and there. And obviously, these things create gaps and issues, and we really don't need that.
Yeah.
Right.
Absolutely.
Yep, I agree.
OK.
Moving on to the next one, I do see the burnout risk is low for her. Like if we talk about the utilization, but being utilized at multiple tickets is the scenario that we have to adhere. The spikes are event driven, so no issue with that as well. But yes, the same would be for like, you know, when she received the hardware request and the other one.
Mm.
Obviously, she's a single resource, that's why she's facing that. But yes, this is something that we can manage now with the addition of new resources as well.
Yep.
After this, all of these are informative slides, but Jim, I really would like you to share any feedback, any concern, or anything that he would like to share about Shivandi and her work culture.
She's doing well. I will definitely take into consideration, you know, any overlapping tickets on her schedule. Try to avoid that. That shouldn't be an issue. So we'll just make sure that her schedule's aligned with what she's actually working on.
Mhm.
No issues, Jim. About the project review as well, I just need her to work on that as well so that she can conclude and close as soon as possible. So if you can just respond to that. I just had a discussion with her in the morning, so she was just waiting for the review. Okay.
Okay.
Yu.
Okay, Jim, that's it from my side. Anything else that we can discuss or are we good to wrap up the call?
No, that's it.
Thank you very much, Jim. I know that you're feeling alone without Karen. She's been on the vacation and you're working over here. But yes, I'll pray for you and may your lease for June and July get extended and you get it approved from Alex.
Yeah.
Well, that'd be great. Alright, Mohit, take care. Thanks.
Okay, Jim, have a great day. Nice to meet you. Bye-bye.
Thanks, bye-bye.